welcome to hannity tonight straight
ahead tonight a special investigation
into nancy pelosi's husband you know the
guy that got the dui but this time the
possibility of insider trading we'll
tell you all about it also anger towards
an armed hero who shot a gunman and
likely saved dozens of lives later we'll
also reveal how border states may have
finally discovered the perfect solution
to joe biden's open borders policies it
might be the perfect solution but first
tonight we are at the end of a typical
monday for our alien commander in chief
while most of you were hard at work
today the president of the united states
he took the day off yet again he was
tired he took a whole trip and
everything with zero public events now
joe needs all the rest he can get after
what was pretty much a disastrous trip
abroad and per usual joe well he failed
to deliver
he never got a commitment from saudi
arabia he's been begging opec begging
the saudis to produce more oil which is
dumb in and of itself because we have
more energy here gas oil coal
that could provide for our needs and so
many other countries needs for hundreds
of years he did not hold the kingdom
accountable for the murder of u.s based
reporter jamal khashoggi there are
conflicting accounts about whether the
subject was even discussed but joe did
get the fist bump with mbs the guy that
he referred to as the murderer pariah
the guy that got away with murder and
when the president finally returned home
to the white house he wasn't really
interested in answering any of your
questions about his embarrassing trip
abroad and it was embarrassing take a
look don't you guys talk about something
i'm happy to answer questions
hey jack all you guys are alike and
everything anyway ultimately this was a
trip that joe biden did not need to make
we have more than enough oil gas coal
right in the ground right here at home
and we could dig domestically not rely
on countries that hate our guts but
according to the religious climate
alarmist cult importing oil from saudi
arabia iran russia venezuela shipping it
across the ocean is much better for
mother earth than producing in our own
country domestically every american
don't we deserve an explanation on this
for this insane thinking
why is it okay to import energy
get extract a barrel of oil abroad but
we can't do it domestically when if we
did it domestically we do it faster we
do it cheaper and we do it cleaner why
wouldn't we do it here joe goes begging
and pleading to pariah nations and comes
home and empty-handed and the price by
the way of a barrel of oil went higher
because joe failed went higher
significantly now even democrats and
biden's protectors and the media mob
even they can't really excuse all of
this away take a look
the fist bumped muhammad bin salman the
man responsible according to biden's own
director of national intelligence for
ordering a brutal murder of a washington
post journalist killing him and then
dismembering him with a bone saw i mean
that fist bump photograph i think a lot
of americans saw that
and were revolted by it should biden
have gone
no i don't think so you have a
leader of that country
who is involved in the murder of a
washington post journalist
i don't think that that type of
government should be rewarded uh with a
visit by the president i don't think
that biden gets a pass just because he's
a democrat just because uh that he's the
democratic president you know i think
that this it's bad no matter
how you look at it
yeah fist bumping the murder did you
notice one thing i noticed in that tape
you see bernie sanders i think he's
actually older than joe uh he's got his
act together he's cognitively alert he
has a lot of energy i don't think he's
changed much in the last 20 years he's
still got his fastball joe doesn't now
everything that is now going wrong for
biden look at this a whopping 75 percent
of american households now saying that
their income is falling behind the cost
of living two-thirds of americans and
going higher living paycheck to paycheck
and as i predicted on this program what
did i say watch the housing market
because that's next now homebuilder
sentiment is beginning to plunge because
of increasing interest rates it's
impacting the market new home
construction will stop sale of
pre-existing homes that will stop home
values will plummet and guess what the
market will crash and then things will
be exponentially worse no surprise biden
is now hemorrhaging support even from
his own base look at the new york times
only 26 percent of democrats want him to
run for reelection and only six percent
six percent of americans under 29 want
biden to serve a second term because
they can't understand half of what he
says anyway and per usual a recent
closed-door fundraiser well there was
his wife the first lady dr jill biden
full of kind of pathetic and lame
excuses telling big donors quote the
president had so many hopes and and
plans and things that he wanted to do
and every time he turned around he had
to address the problems of the moment
and he just had so many so many horrible
things thrown his way
um now i'm not sure what you expected
jill biden that's called being president
that's why it's the hardest job on earth
that's why you need your faculties about
you what part of that did you not get
going into that job now did you not
think that biden would face unexpected
challenges and problems as the leader of
the free world did you really think it
would be that easy he was vice president
at least in name only for eight years
did you think a guy struggling like your
husband is with a steep cognitive
decline a precipitous decline could
perform the duties of the presidency i
guess apparently so because now joe
biden is so clearly in over his head and
every week it gets worse and worse and
worse the rnc put together a compilation
now look at this from two perspectives
one as an american citizen this is your
president and two think about america's
enemies hostile regimes that hate this
country think of china russia iran
venezuela
north korea and ask yourself what are
they thinking when they see this
the best way to get something done if
you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to
anyway
from
from uh
char excuse me from charlotte
one
another line going from in florida down
to tampa the idea that
los angeles and and
what am i doing here
for two reasons
one
to
we haven't been able to communicate it
in a way that is uh um
i might say another way
how do you feel
forget about democrat republican does
that guy seem up to the job of being
president he obviously is not what you
saw sadly is also just the tip of the
iceberg in fact to drive home the point
let's play a few more clips just to
really really etch this into your mind
what
what do american enemies hostile regimes
think when they see this from a united
states president you decide
the political coverage
[Applause]
[Music]
that
look
um
some of the political
players and some of the
[Music]
let me ask you a rhetorical question
no anyway
so a guy that's struggling to speak read
and remember simple basic facts and
names and follow basic simple
instructions
say hello sit down from a note card is
not capable of being president a guy who
needs long weekends to recover from one
trip one traveling experience does not
have the stamina to be president a guy
who wakes up late goes to bed early
should not be president a guy that turns
and tries to shake hands with thin air
again and again and again
shouldn't be president and ask what do i
do now i can't take questions or they'll
get mad at me and finally almost
everyone agrees with what we've now been
telling you from the beginning joe biden
is not fit to be president he's not fit
to serve he should be spending his final
years enjoying retirement on a beach in
delaware not screwing up the country in
the white house and putting the entire
world in harm's way and unfortunately
for democrats the options to replace joe
in 2024 they're not looking great either
to say the least according to the
washington post you got what their their
number one replacement candidate is
mayor pete
you know the transportation secretary
who's now spending a billion taxpayer
dollars to make our highways less
racist he's now leading the democratic
pac behind him vice president kamala
harris who is one of the most unpopular
politicians in the entire country we can
call her the giggling vice president
biden's borders are is not exactly busy
solving the border crisis and she is not
exactly inspiring the nation with some
of the the worst speeches ever given in
the history of that office harris
typically sounds like she's giving a
book report for a novel that she never
read she only read the cliff notes
latest example take a look
it's because of what you did then
so i'm here to ask you
to do what you know how to do
because when you do what you do
on all of these issues the american
people win
do what you have to do what you do every
due day
apparently the vice president is even
worse behind closed doors two more top
aides just announced their departure
including the director of speech
who served for only four months uh i you
can't blame the
the vice president so i guess you fire
the speechwriter which brings the total
number of resignations in the vice
president's office now to a whopping 11.
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else